ein mann für die komplizierten fälle ein
portemonnaie dass jemand dem backofen
versteckt und dann vergessen hat da muss
man erst mal schauen ob ich da ran komme
ohne uns kaputt zu schneiden
verbranntes geld ist das spezialgebiet
von frank herzog
er muss die reste der scheine
zusammenpuzzeln um herauszufinden wie
viel tatsächlich in der börse war
hier sollen es scheine im wert von 220
euro gewesen sein
mir sind
von denen muss auch im verband zu stein
mehr als 50 vorhanden sein um sie
erstatten zu können
sonst können ihr einer hingehen einem
kleineren oder 2 x einreichen
das heißt man wird praktisch das geld
verdoppeln
er und seine 14 kollegen prüfen jährlich
beschädigtes bargeld im wert von 30
millionen euro
der umtausch ist kostenlos auch bei
aufwendigen fällen wie diesem
diese banken haben sich mit der börse
verbunden sind verschmolzen
ich muss aber auf jeden fall nachschauen
ob die rechte teile der bank oder auch
vorhanden sind
nur dann können wir das kind auch
erstatten herzog arbeitet im
analysezentrum der deutschen bundesbank
diese beschädigten münzen wurden
offiziell aus dem verkehr gezogen
umtausch ausgeschlossen
anders diese verfaulten scheine die im
garten vergraben waren aus angst vor
dieben und auch die alten d mark noten
können noch in euro umgetauscht werden
der kollege nebenan ist der detektiv im
haus diese scheine sind falschgeld
oft sieht er sofort aus welcher
fälscherwerkstatt die scheibe kommen
fälschung fühlen sich oftmals clutter an
banknotenpapier ist sehr griffig das
nicht aus handelsüblichen papier
hergestellt sondern reine baumwolle
das heißt erfüllt da schon was besonders
gute fälschungen vom original zu
unterscheiden
dafür braucht er technik im uv-licht
leuchtet nur falschgeld
und die vergrößerung zeigt jeden
druckfehler
es gibt lose fälle die schon abstrusen
wo man mal 300 euro note bekommt dies so
zahlungsverkehr gar nicht gibt und
trotzdem werden auch solche noten
angenommen also alles was wir geld
aussieht funktioniert an der einen oder
anderen stelle
frank herzog hat inzwischen mit ganz
anderen gaunern zu tun
mäuse haben das versteck eines kunden
auf dem dachboden geplündert
das schwierige an den mäuse fraß fällen
ist einfach dass diese weise spahn
heraus fressen und diese zum nestbau
benutzen und diese somit wegtragen
in diesem fall aber war die maus
genügsamen herzog wird wohl alle scheine
zur hälfte zusammen bekommen und der
kunde sein geld zurück